Much of the communication that we do
across our networks is between two
devices. Device A communicates to device
B and device B communicates back to
device A. The attackers though would
like to be able to see everything
happening in that communication between
those devices. And to be able to do
that, they've devised a series of
attacks known as onpath attacks. This is
how someone gets in the middle of a
conversation to be able to monitor and
in some cases change the information
that's being sent from one device to
another. What's interesting about an on
path attack is that the end stations
that are communicating may have no idea
that their communication is being
monitored. This means that security
software that is monitoring information
on the end stations may not have any
idea that an onpath attack is taking
place. One popular form of onpath attack
is one that you can do on a local
subnet. This is referred to as ARP
poisoning or ARP spoofing. This allows
someone to sit in the middle of a
conversation and be able to look at all
of the traffic going back and forth. One
of the reasons that ARP poisoning is
able to work so well is that there's no
security built into the address
resolution protocol. Let's look at a
normal ARP communication. You might have
two devices on the network. One is a
laptop which has an IP address of
192.168.1.9
and you can see that it has a MAC
address that ends in 38 delta 5. We also
on this network have a router. Its IP
address is 192.168.1.1
and its MAC address ends in Bravo Bravo
Fox Echo. On this network, the laptop
may need to communicate to the router to
be able to send information to another
subnet. But this laptop only has the IP
address of that router and does not have
the MAC address. In order to obtain the
MAC address, that laptop will send out
an ARP request. This ARP request sends a
broadcast looking for the IP address of
192.168.1.1.
And if we find that device, we would
like that device to send back their MAC
address. This broadcast is obviously
going to be seen by the router. And the
router is going to send back a response
that says I am 192.168.1.1
and my MAC address is the one listed
here that ends in bravo bravo fox echo.
Once that ARP response is received by
the instation, it is put into a local
cache on this device where it is paired
up the IP address and the MAC address.
Now let's see how an attacker might
create ARP spoofing to exploit that
communication path. The attacker has an
IP address of 192.168.1.14.
So it's on the same subnet as the router
and the laptop. And you'll notice that
the MAC address of this attacker ends an
echoech fox. The attacker is going to
send an ARP response directly to the
laptop. Even though the laptop has not
sent out an ARP request because of the
way that ARP works, that response will
be received by that laptop and will be
processed. The attacker's ARP response
says that the attacker is 192.168.1.1
and it has a MAC address that ends in
echoech fox. You can see that the IP
address of the attacker is not that IP
address, but it is that MAC address.
That means when this laptop receives
that response, it will change the
information that is contained within the
cache. We still have that original
192.168.1.1
IP address. But notice now that the MAC
address for that IP address in the ARP
cache has been modified to end in
echoech fox, which is the same MAC
address as the attacker. Now, anytime
that this laptop wants to send
information to the router, it will
instead send that information to the
attacker's workstation. Most attackers
will perform the same art poisoning to
the router and now it can sit in the
middle of the conversation and watch all
of the traffic being sent between both
of these devices.
Instead of having the attacker on the
network, what if the attacker was on the
laptop? This would be an onpath browser
attack that takes a proxy software on
that browser and uses that to sit in the
middle of a conversation. Because the
attacker has found a way to install this
proxy software onto this local device.
All of that communication is being
redirected on the browser itself. This
looks completely normal to the victim.
All of the web pages visited by the
victim look perfectly normal and they
have no idea that this proxy is sitting
in the middle of this conversation. Now
all the attacker has to do is wait for
you to log in to your bank or some other
important site and now they have access
to your login credentials.
The attacker's software may not even
have to send that information to the
attacker, but instead exploit that
particular vulnerability on the same
local system. For example, you might
open a browser and visit your bank's
website and add your username and
password. At that point, the attacker
has gathered that information with the
internal proxy on your system. From this
point, the proxy can begin accessing
your bank account directly and could
effectively gain access to all of your
funds.
One place that an attacker could use an
onpath attack might be on an open
wireless network that you might find in
an airport, a coffee shop, or any other
public area. This is something called a
wireless evil twin where a separate
access point is created that has a very
similar look and feel as the existing
access points on that network. The
attacker will create an access point
that has the same SSID or network name.
It has the same security settings and
they might even create a captive portal
screen that looks very similar to the
one that currently exists. This may work
just as being another access point
that's on the edge of this network. Or
the attackers might increase the power
output of their access point to
overwhelm the access points that are
legitimate. If you're moving through an
airport or you're at a coffee shop, you
might not even notice that there are
multiple access points with the same
name that you can connect to. And
although the end users think they're
connecting to a legitimate network,
they're actually connecting to the
attacker's access point. Now the
attacker can see all of the wireless
communication going back and forth and
they can simply monitor that data or
they can modify the information that's
being sent. This is just one of the
reasons that you constantly hear us
telling you to use encrypted channels
when you are communicating across the
network. You should certainly be
connecting to websites that use HTTPS.
That's the secure version of HTTP. And
ideally, if you are outside your network
on a public network, you are always
using a virtual private network or VPN.